did somebody say baby back ribs
I don't think Christian has time for
that I have time
I want my baby back baby I want my baby
baby baby back I want my baby back
baby back ribs
Warden
your squad busted Melanie Hawkins
you're getting out come with me okay
wait
can I do one thing first
I wanted to say goodbye I can't believe
you saved my life I would not do it
again it really hurt nah but you did do
it and I regret it so much Caleb you're
ruining this look I just wanted to say
thank you for everything you got me
through this I'm gonna miss you oh put
it there pal
start by going over the needs of the
County right
well Lackawanna County has not been
immune to the slow economic growth over
the past five years so for us the name
of the game is budget reduction Awesome
Blossom
what
I think we should share an awesome
Blossom what do you say they are awesome
you want to Christian awesome sure okay
it's done
actually Megan may we have an awesome
Blossom please extra awesome now it is
done so um
very very funny joke the other day you
want to hear it Christian need it you
don't have to listen to this
week it's okay I like jokes okay
just the one just one joke okay well if
it's just gonna be one I will think of a
different joke
um
don't let them see us blend in I gotta
tell you cop work is a lot like Hannibal
work really oh yeah the watching
the following
the waiting for soccer practice to end
come on man I can't believe this I'm
gonna die in here and then you're gonna
eat my castrated body I guess but it'd
be a pretty boring meal without dessert
oh my God first guy says well I'm an
astronaut so I drive a Saturn and the
second guy says well I am a pimp so I
drive a cheap escort and the third guy
says I got you both beat I'm a
proctologist so I drive a brown probe
oh
my God that's funny I almost had Awesome
Blossom coming out of my nose
Katana please
Jake it's so good to see you come give
me a hug I'm not gonna eat you also
don't hug me because I will try to eat
you
this is such a surprise I haven't seen
you since I transferred here how's Amy
she's great we're married and she's a
sergeant now wow yeah how's everything
here yeah same old same old guess who's
here Herman Herman always playing
Yahtzee knew everybody's name worship
Satan did he he never mentioned that
shut up about it is exhausting well I'm
Charles I'm Jake's best friend Charles
he's serving three life sentences no
need to flex so Caleb we're tracking a
serial killer and I was thinking you
could help us get inside his head just
because I ate humans doesn't mean that
I'm inhuman Jake Caleb come on that's
not what I meant I'm just kidding I'm
probably friends with a guy online
what's his deal well he's been murdering
young men and cutting out their hearts
ooh what I would never eat a hard I
stick to the normal stuff butts and
thighs one time I ate a foot but it was
nasty yeah I could see that you know
what there was some weird guy on the
Forum recently before him yeah it's a
chat room for people who like to talk
about eating human beings but definitely
won't act on it wink yeah it's hosted on
Reddit obviously anyways he showed up
from out of nowhere asking questions
about cutting out Hearts really do you
know anything else about him I've never
seen him on there before but you could
check the logs I'll approve you I'm an
admin oh you might want to switch to
incognito mode otherwise your targeted
ads will be pretty cannibal specific ah
good to know well it was good to see you
Caleb Sammy that info
so after watching my mom go through so
much pain I decided to keep that promise
that I made to her and take care of her
well this brings us to Jan Truth or Dare
tell us about your divorce oh no Michael
Michael you right Michael please no no
oh really hey you're not gonna play
she's not playing she's not playing the
game we've been fighting for a while he
didn't want kids I knew that going into
it but he also knew that I did so I
guess I thought that he would change his
mind he thought that I would change mine
you didn't
I was stupid no no you were not stupid
Gould was stupid right that's right you
know Really Brave I mean you you put
your arms out there you slit your wrist
that's true you said world this is my
blood it's red just like yours so love
me
I'm sorry where is Liz Lemon she's out
of the office is there anything we can
help you with we've got about
10 minutes before we've got to go watch
shopping well this does affect the two
of you I'm Martin Luther King from NBC's
in-house Council a former TGs employee
has followed the harassment lawsuit
against this production and both of you
individually complainant is seeking
damages in the amount of 50 million
dollars
all my calls giant B
I assume you know this woman what's her
name okay start from the beginning well
the plaintiff's deposition alleges that
no further back what kind of dinosaur
was your grandfather
um the plaintiff alleges that there is a
widespread culture of depravity here at
TGs sexual harassment intimidation
threats of violence her deposition is
very gross I'm going to use this doll to
show you what Tracy and Jenna did to me
no no
oh God
she's lying like a rug rug is an
offensive term for Persians that I made
up we would never do that to a page
maybe that tall Asian one oh yeah
Miranda her hair is so thick and black
please don't include me in this look
legal views this is a frivolous lawsuit
Hazel lost her name AKA Richard wrench
has a long history of suing former
employers so all we need is for everyone
who works at TGs to sign this affidavit
saying that they have never witnessed or
been party to any inappropriate behavior
I once played a lawyer in the movie so I
know all about winning your son's love
back thanks to a Magic Camera yes movies
are terrible well don't worry we'll get
everyone to sign we really don't want
this to go to court for a number of
reasons YouTube will be personally
liable for any damages Hank Hooper hates
any type of negative publicity like this
and I didn't super duper finish law
school so
right down the street
Kenneth Road born and raised spent my
whole life right here in Lackawanna
County and I do not intend on moving
I know this place I know how many
hospitals we have I have
schools we have it's home you know
I know the challenges
counties up against here's the thing
about those discount suppliers they
don't care they come in they undercut
everything and they run us out of
business and then once we're all gone we
jack up the prices I don't know it's bad
it's terrible it is you know what it
really is
I don't know
I guess I could give you guys a business
but you have to meet me halfway okay
because they're expecting me to make
cuts
it's gonna go ballistic but
but could Jan
perhaps we should pay your accountable
friend another visit I wouldn't say
they're friends so much as ex-sellmates
no that's true we're friends he ate kids
well people are complicated
and one thing you are not looking for a
cannibal why do you say that with all
that blood no self-respecting cannibal
would waste all that sauce see Charles
he's a foodie like you who are you can I
see that picture again oh man those are
some nice tools I would love to spread
some ribs using that sternum retractor
but they only sell those to hospitals
wait a minute
what'd you just say I said I love to get
my little fingers and some chesties no
no no not the super gross part surgery
grade tools precise incisions around the
heart and there was no ice at the motel
because the purp was using it for the
hearts we're not looking for a serial
killer he stole the hearts for a
transplant boom we solved it boy oh give
me a hug
for the record I'm not a cannibal
anymore my new passion is needlepoint
embroidery look at these two parrots in
love
a turtle with a monocle and a top hat
wow it's so intricate
okay you got me I was gonna eat you
that's still my thing it's even affected
my needlepoint look at this liver
a heart
but
an arm